on va parler de ce bras de fer sur le
passe à nanterre avec notre reporter
nadège abderrazak
[Musique]
bonjour la neige alors un long bras de
fer encore cette semaine sur la question
du passé ni terre
absolument olivier alors dans le post
dans le contexte d'une possible
cinquième vague de covin 19 le projet de
loi vigilance sanitaire permettent au
gouvernement de recourir à l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et aux mesures
exceptionnelles notamment le pass
sanitaires ou encore l'obligation
vaccinale pour certaines professions
le texte un va être examiné en seconde
lecture à l'assemblée nationale ce
mercredi pourquoi et bien parce que
députés et sénateurs n'ont pas pu se
mettre d'accord sur un texte commun en
commission mixte paritaire à leur rôle
rappel l'assemblée nationale est dominée
par la majorité présidentielle
alors qu'au sénat c'est la droite qui
domine quels sont les points de
désaccord alors en ce qui concerne
l'état d'urgence et la prolongation du
passé sanitaires le gouvernement est
favorable à une prolongation jusqu'au 31
juillet 2022 alors le sénat dit oui à
une prolongation mais pas aussi tard le
sénat lui a choisi la date du 28 février
2022 pourquoi et bien parce qu'ils
estiment qu' il refuse en fait de donner
les pleins pouvoirs à l'exécutif pendant
ces huit prochains mois les sénateurs
préfèrent également une
conditionnelle utilisation du pass
sanitaires aux départements qui n'ont
pas encore atteint un taux de
vaccination de au moins 80% alors après
une seconde lecture à l'assemblée
nationale ce mercredi ce projet de loi
est bien va être repassé devant le sénat
ce jeudi avant un retour à l'assemblée
nationale vendredi l'assemblée qui aura
donc le dernier mot sur ce dossier
si beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions neige à des razak